[Music]
Brand X it's gonna be on FX
I heard you announce it Brand X with
Russell Brand it's like but the my name
is in the title of it yes
Brand X with Russell Bratz like I really
need to hear my name a lot guess what my
shows called Conan O'Brien Conan O'Brien
just Conan just Conan yeah being shouted
at the world it screams it people I need
to be able to move the moon yeah that's
what I said it's gonna be my name and
the moon moves when I want it to except
then big butch buff guys that put your
mics on there so relaxed
anyway Brand X let's talk about this
show what time of night is this show on
the exact time that this one is you and
I are locked in a war were in or rating
we're we're in mortal kombat you and I
luckily Conan the results of this war
are meaningless exactly like say like
it's not like a real war it's I don't
know now we're gonna have to adopt your
religious system of your flag like me
but they just won't matter it won't
matter the the important thing is that
you're doing gonna do a very funny show
that's important opposite this show
that's so important well I think it's
gonna be a very funny show nothing is
important they said to just get enough
food and be kind I usually have sex
possibly with the sound man these are
terrific rules to live by
why even continue with this show right
now let's not bother just tip this drink
on the ground
tranquil waiting for the revolution but
that woman's gonna do with an axe one
woman woman in our audience is gonna
lead the revolution we have a clip here
from you I did that now feel guilty
someone it's only water it was something
sticky other than obviously bodily
effluvia she's frightened me so do you
what should we show this clip I don't
know what's this clip is I have know
nothing about a clip designed to promote
my show I have come here mostly to
promote my show here is a clip that will
promote that show of mine on Conan the
moon mover
president in a way is our leader and
it's unthinkable do you know what the
president has to be it is to a degree a
religious figure but but the American
presidents obligations they're obviously
political but also corporate like you
know like you know something so they
don't go too far down that line but like
what I think is important here sounding
me well I think is important here is the
reason that they'll allama could be
celebrated he's not a three because he's
a Santa Claus figure that's like us
practicing to make the show writing
jokes for it the show sort of like a
live show me talking telling jokes and
tell it's saying that what I've
considered to be the truth about stories
in the news oh it's only another
person's opinion yeah you're gonna have
guests on the show I don't think so
because they would stop me talking so
you look at you now you could be talking
now if I were near but I love it when
you talk maybe I should shut up and
usual I'm not as secure as you I don't
know if that's true I think we're both
very secure people problems occur only
Andy sandy is the most secure one of the
three of us he's like a wise pizza
eating Buddha that's right
yes hey let me ask you something is this
true that the Dalai Lama was going to
speak to the youth of Manchester is this
correct and he asked you to introduce
him yeah and I did it I met the Dalai
Lama I was with the Dalai Lama what we
should be talking about yeah it was
amazing what's he like really kind he
shook my hand for too long he's like
good like that and anything let go of it
until we were in another room I don't
even know how we got there just let go
of his hand I was somewhere else now I
like he laughed at me like a mean laugh
people that guy looks like a leprechaun
laughing at you because you didn't get
the gold what do you want that gold
leprechaun could have as much gold as it
wants why is it just not give us the
gold bloody leprechauns and that's my
message well we ended up when this
interview began I thought will we end up
with a proper message for America yeah
and we did with super Koons give up your
gold
[Laughter]